we just developed a slow cooker for
beautiful which is the kitchen line that
i created and designed with all of the
people that i work with and a slow
cooker is something that i'm really
passionate about because
there are recipes that can entail a
whole lot of business before going in
the slow cooker or there are some where
you can literally throw it in turn it on
and come back to a gorgeous meal so i'm
going to demonstrate one of those and
pilar is going to demonstrate the
dessert version this is so revelatory i
never think sweet when i see slow cooker
i always think savory yeah so you are
blowing my mind and also showing again
the versatility of this gorgeous slow
cooker now i'm gonna demonstrate a
slow-cooked pork carnitas this is a
recipe near and dear to my heart okay
now here's what i'm gonna show you how
to do first of all you're gonna put your
meat directly in the slow cooker
so i am using a pork shoulder i have
cumin and oregano in here and cumin is
truly one of my favorite spices um it's
pretty much in most things that i'm
obsessed with i think it's all over our
recipes in the book as well
so you're gonna
take that spice and work it through the
meat just to flavor it
and then you're literally going to throw
it in your slow cooker it's
rogue piece watch out
watch out for those little pieces and if
there's any that you missed just right
in the slow cooker grab it
salt it
continue to stir
now part of the seasoning is also the
salsa um this is something i created
because i love tomatillas and usually
when you get tacos it's a red or a pico
de gallo and i love a nice green verde
salsa so this is so simple it is
literally
garlic
onions tomatillo
cilantro
jalapenos and the secret ingredient
is a little bit of beer
it just gives it that extra flavor
profile
um that
really really does it for me um
literally
that is it now you can cook it low and
slow
um for six to eight hours or you can
kick up the heat a tiny bit and actually
like on a medium or high and that
reduces your cooking time down to four
to six hours
and come back to a gorgeous meal with
incredible texture
can we get to taste
now
one of the things that's so important is
to get that restaurant style quality
you've got to get that fork out and
shred it so don't be scared if there's
still some chunks in place that's
totally natural and normal you can get
two forks actually and go at the same
time in sort of that formation and then
you can put your little fixings on the
side smells incredible and um i noticed
we have a little pickled onion here yeah
that really works well with this recipe
also a little cr i know i'm dying cheers
cheers i love you i love you
and it's all due to some seasoning and
some slow cooking palar
your turn i'm like wait i'm busy eating
hold on
i kind of threw it to you so i could
keep
[Music]
you